floods came as a complete surprise to
many on highway 265 in germany people
were returning home from work
but near the town of afstad in north
rhino's phallia they were suddenly
confronted with a wall of water 12
meters high
remarkably everyone survived
there'd been three days of torrential
rain in some places up to 150
millimeters in just 48 hours germany
normally gets about half of that in the
whole of july
in nearby towns and villages along the
river are there was also shock at the
sudden rise in water levels and there
were tragic consequences incinsic 12
residents in a home for the disabled
died when they weren't evacuated in time
what remains of these horrifying moments
are the thick layers of mud sweeping
through houses restaurants and shops
people's lives have been changed forever
we met priest heiku marketing in the
historic wine town of awhile where
dozens of people died he tells us of a
man who lost both his parents told me
the image of the woman
being swept away waving her hand crying
for help
you know
i have to
yeah they didn't make it and
i'm not sure if they were found
across the border in belgium where at
least 40 people died a criminal
investigation has begun to find out who
is responsible for a failure in the
warning system
we have nothing left no home no
furniture or clothes it's so hard but i
say to myself at least i saved my child
as a mother that's the most important
the river most birthed its banks and
flooded parts of liage province
including hundreds of municipalities
there was also damage on the dutch side
of the border in the town of falconburg
with estimates the cost could reach
billions of dollars
while the water has receded the images
of these sudden deadly floods will
remain with people forever
some experts say building better
production measures won't be enough in
the future and more steps need to be
taken to prevent temperatures rising
only then can people feel safe again
while it's definitely a wake-up call for
people here affected by these floods the
question now is is it also a wake-up
call for the government immediately
after this disaster happens angela
merkel chancellor angela merkel made
this connection with climate change but
she will end her term uh after 16 years
after elections in september and a
possible successor armin laschat who is
actually also the prime minister of one
of these very badly affected areas north
reinward's violent has been criticized
for not doing enough to have this energy
transition that is so important here in
germany
speed up so the question remains if this
wake-up call will affect the people here
who have to vote at the end of september
and then we will know if it's a wake-up
call or just business as usual back to
you nick
all right step thanks very much indeed
thanks for that to step western there in
germany
indeed as we've had the science now the
science is unequivocal say the ipcc now
it is up to the government's next stop
will be glasgow at the beginning of
november the un climate summit and
people are saying that if that summit
fails then all bets are off
for these kind of events for the extreme
weather events that we've been seeing
and ongoing climate change it really is
up to world leadership to do something
about this now